[Music]
I'm the one
okay so we got a special podcast for you
here today it's not often you have two
Michaels two mics yes two heavyweights
in their own space one that's true the
great Michael Francis the other the
great Mike Tyson yeah but to start off
because we like building anticipation
we're going to start off with Michael
Francis first and then Mike is going to
work his way in here in a minute but
Michael it's great to have you on a
podcast good I'm the opener today yeah
yeah today always good to be back how
many times have we done stuff together
at this point a lot yeah I I can't uh
keep count the other day God was asking
the questions and so you know when how
did you and Michael get connected I said
man it was not supposed to even happen
because I was running late from Jordan
belfor's house and he was gracious
enough to wait and we went to his house
he was so pissed off he didn't even put
shoes on it was in his socks and it was
the most common thing about Michael sock
look at Michael's power play not wearing
any shoes
people ask me was Patrick disrespectful
when he came to your house he didn't
take his shoes off
but uh it's exciting to have you on
obviously we got some things to talk
about with you and Mike a big project
you guys are working on Champions Corner
we'll get into them once he gets here
I'm excited to uh learn more about that
but uh Michael A lot's been happening
since the last time you and I spoke on a
live podcast we've spoken obviously
about different kind of issues one of
the things I want to just with the time
that we have here before we get uh Mike
here what are your thoughts about what
happened with Tucker what happened with
Fox you know his next move you know
Fox's mistake is their stuff that we're
not thinking about what are some things
you saw when that announcement was made
well I really think Tucker was
blindsided I mean we you know we chatted
a little bit back and forth they didn't
know what was going to happen but
you know Patrick it just seems today
that
you can't say anything that's going to
offend anybody in any way you know the
news is not what the news was before I
mean everything is about opinions and
who you're gonna you know offend or not
offend and
you know I mean I I think it was crazy
you know to take a guy like that off the
air I mean who had such a huge following
I mean honestly it doesn't affect him he
can go anywhere he wants as you know but
I I couldn't believe it I can't believe
you know on a whole what's going on it's
unbelievable yeah really he he's a he's
a once in a generation type of yeah
you've been around the block for for a
while so you've watched who was it
before rush by the way was there a rush
before rush or I don't believe okay so
let's just say rush let's go Rush
O'Reilly Beck Megan Tucker when you look
at all these names especially on the
conservative side where do you rank
Tucker amongst those five oh my God he's
right up on top now I mean really you
put him ahead of Rush
well rush rush is like an institution
you know he's been around so long I mean
you know what I was in jail when I first
started hearing I didn't know who he was
but I started listening to him and I
started to realize you know I was always
a Democrat mob guys are always Democrats
and the reason is because they were
easier to corrupt so you know we were
all with Democrats why are them so much
easier to corrupt they just were willing
to take more money there yeah they just
were they have no backbone what is it
you know I can't explain it because we
didn't get involved with Republicans
they were all Democrats in in New York
and we got involved with them but I'm in
the hole and I'm listening to Rush
Limbaugh and I'm saying you know what I
think I'm a conservative because I agree
with a lot of the things this guy is
saying and that's how I became uh that's
when I realized I was conservative it
was from Rush so rush so you so you put
Rush slightly ahead of Tucker I think so
because he was around so long and he
what he built is unbelievable really and
his style was was what was Rowdy he
would he would call everybody out he was
was he the intellectual guy as well as
the history guy as well as the call-out
troll you know the showman what made him
special what made rush rush honestly
yeah I mean he was honest you know he
whatever he said he whatever he felt he
said and I thought he was brilliant a
very very smart guy very well read he
knew exactly what he was talking about
he called him what did he call himself
like it was Einstein you know brain from
God or something but but uh just this
his whole style I mean he uh it was
great and and you know Patrick when
somebody is so good for so long you got
to give him you know a lot of credit he
was great he was a guy that started all
this back to the Tucker situation yeah
you know we had that conversation that
sit down some may call it last
Thursday
and some people were basically believed
that Tucker was sort of fired
as a byproduct of the Dominion lawsuit
where they wanted ahead they wanted a
scapegoat to see all right we got the
money but we also got this how much do
you think that was factored into into
Tucker's situation I think that was part
of it but I heard you know he was not
that he intentionally did it but in the
way he spoke he offended Murdoch in a
big way some of the things that he said
you know about some of the people there
I heard he gave a a speech you know at a
college a couple of days before Heritage
yeah Heritage and uh it was very
offensive according to you know the
people at Fox so it's a couple of things
and you know I think Fox thinks hey we
let Megan go
we survived we let Riley go O'Reilly we
survived so I think maybe they thought
you know they can survive again I don't
know how you replace Tucker Michael
honestly to to kind of maybe use
honestly a mafia analogy here Murdoch's
the boss yeah that's the that's
El Jefe
you know to use a mafia analogy like
should should a flag carrier a a talking
head ever offend the boss like what's
the you know if you can make some
Synergy and to this situation well on
the street you don't do that you just
don't do that you know that's dangerous
right but you know you're talking about
Corporate America it shouldn't be like
that and and he didn't do this to offend
the boss he just spoke what he felt to
be true you know I mean I found him to
be very honest you spend time with
Tucker no I have not oh you haven't okay
he's very genuine very very honest and
he says what he feels and I think he
really cares he really does because we
talked off camera about certain things
and he uh you know it didn't mean to be
offensive he just spoke his piece that
was it what do you I mean I don't know
uh you know if if the guy is the guy at
the top of the company you're at that
you're paying nine out of ten times
you're gonna have problems if you're
gonna do it that way to me the way to do
it is to do it to his face not behind
like any time I've had issues with the
guy that I am working
four right I've had bosses in my life
I always had an issue with one time with
this one uh lady I was working with she
was about to make a very bad decision
terrible decision and it had to do with
one of our friends you met him before
you know who lived in France for seven
years who has a great accent and you've
spent a lot of time with them he likes
to walk around with no clothes on he's
like that gentleman with no clothes on
so one day I get a ward that he's about
to lose a lot of money
and she was making a decision because
from the top it was kind of be an
influence for her to do so everybody
that was working with this lady was not
supportive of the decision she was about
to make
I call her up I said can I meet you guys
at the house tonight at midnight I go to
the house at midnight we have a two-hour
conversation I said look I'm gonna give
you my argument I think you're making a
terrible decision here but I don't want
to do it in front of everybody I want to
just kind of do it privately to you and
hopefully you'll receive it and then you
do what you do with it so I did
and she ended up actually not
doing what she was going to do to that
guy which I got a lot of respect for the
fact that she didn't do it because she
was reasonable enough to receive the
argument so to me I think if you're
gonna do it you know I I would go
one-on-one now at the same time on the
flip side we don't know the whole story
the whole story could be Tucker's been
trying to get there for a while and
nobody's been listening to him and he's
the go to the organization and how do
you not listen to your best guy if an
organization
has a person like that sometimes people
talk you don't have like if you ever
read the book principles Ray dalio you
know people would come in and they would
say we should do this in the company we
should do that in the company you don't
do this and you don't do that and you
don't do this he says there's a lot of
people that I want to tell you how to
run a company and they haven't earned
the moral authority to tell you how to
run the company but then on certain
people that have earned the right to
tell you you know feedback on blind
spots the company may have if there's
anybody that had moral authority to give
feedback to Fox it was tuck across them
what so whether it was received or not
behind closed doors it is what it is the
guy that did it right and had a lot of
issues with the owner was Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan and Steve you know Jerry
Krause and Jerry Jerry Rice two Jerry's
you know he had issues with you I would
always say look people come here to
watch the players play but we respect
this and we respect that and look what
happened with Michael Michael's a
multi-billionaire today and so there's
ways to handle it I don't know the whole
story uh behind closed doors but uh if
you're gonna think you're gonna find day
once in a generation type of a guy like
Tucker it's going to be hard to find a
guy like that but here's the here's the
deal
in mainstream media who who would you
consider as the Yankees when it comes on
to politics
CNN you put CNN as Yankees over Fox I
mean if you go to any airport any
mainstream Outlet they're going to have
CNN on
that's more a affiliation right that's
not if you're talking numbers I'm
talking numbers you're going to put Fox
right okay who was the most hated
organization in Major League Baseball
the Yankees who's the most hated NFL
organization Cowboys Cowboys who's the
most hated in the NBA you can go on here
these are institutions you want to play
for in our times Jim Buss made some
stupid decisions at times remember when
they had Steve Nash and Dwight Howard
and all this I don't know if you
remember this yeah of course the Lakers
yeah so you know are the Yankees going
to come back and find somebody they
probably will uh is is the audience
gonna come back the audience that they
lost we don't know there's an audience
that's 65 plus that's maybe not going to
convert to YouTube maybe not going to
convert to Spotify you don't know that
uh uh those people are wanting to come
home and just go like this they don't
want to come home and go on YouTube Loop
boom stream to the computer boom they
want to just be like go to Fox go to CNN
to that audience that audience may be
lost to the audience that's going to
come running go find them like people
like us we're gonna go find them no
matter where the guy goes but the 65
plus I don't know if they want to take
three steps to go listen to the person I
think they won once what are you saying
the future of fox looks like at this
point I mean if they lost their MJ if
they lost their Kobe meet somebody they
could listen Michael said a bit he says
no player is bigger than the NBA and he
was right and let me ask you you think
you know Murdoch is at a point in time
where you know economically he doesn't
need anything he's an older guy does he
really care so his audience dropped like
you said he figures out somebody will
come he'll replace it this is the cycle
this is how it goes yeah here's the only
difference though this is the only thing
where I think is problematic with this
versus the NBA okay so in the NBA what
changes Styles change you know like
defense like Frank volcker was a
defensive coach let's just say Dan Tony
was a what offensive coach which we're
going to score 138 points with Nash Kobe
and of them okay so anyways you kind of
put these things where styles that play
right but in when it comes down to Media
when Jerry Springer who's a former mayor
of Cincinnati is doing a show is the
number one show in on TV he says I want
to start talking about serious issues
his producer says what are you talking
about that's not you man you're supposed
to entertain I want to start talking
about serious issues so for a minute
they allowed him to talk about serious
issues you know what happened to his
viewers they disappeared yeah because
his viewers don't want to talk about
serious issues they want to laugh they
want like oh my god did you see that guy
there's no way this guy got it's not his
baby they want to see that they want to
see drama right okay so Fox with the two
new Sons the two sons not new they've
been around for a minute but the two
sons new owners if they decide to change
philosophically to go get an eyeball
they'll get destroyed that's a complete
different strategy that's got nothing to
do with Tucker Carlson if you try to you
know like look at Elon Elon brings this
girl this girl from um yeah where'd that
come from yeah so the audience that was
all Elon all Twitter is now is like wait
a minute I thought it wasn't about
advertising I thought it was about
subscription why are you bringing
somebody that was a leader you know that
was sitting on the you know World
economic forum and she said this by
BlackRock and she said this about you
know uh uh NBC ESG and NBC and fake news
is unrealists the younger audience that
thinks it's fake because they consume
podcasts they're real fake the people
that watch real media they know it's not
real fake news I mean you bring somebody
like that that's a philosophical hire
that some people are confused with right
now how it ends up turning out nobody
knows no one knows what's going to
happen with Fox and Tucker we're gonna
learn within three years who made the
right decision Tucker wins great Fox
wins great everyone moves on but it's
going to take about two to three years I
also think we should we'd be remiss if
we didn't bring up the number one power
player in media who runs Fox it's not
necessarily the murdochs it's Suzanne
Scott right what do you think her role
is in all this I know you've studied her
a little bit
me I'm not really familiar no it's hot
I'm sorry
her role in what in in everything I mean
she's got to be a she's at the seat of
the board she's the CEO of Fox News
she's not the I've never member of the
board I don't know who she is all I know
is the people I've spoken to and what
they've said about her
um she's uh you know she she based on
what I'm hearing she's not the nicest
person to work with and she's uh she's
tough to work with and you know
sometimes how certain people you know
don't get the eyeballs but they think
the organization is winning because of
them she's exactly the GM of uh of the
Chicago Bulls
that's her she's Jerry Krause that's the
feeling you get because she has a
Michael that she can't keep happy yeah
okay so people like that
um make it tough to but at the same time
listen
when they when they were making a
promotion apparently they needed
somebody to be uh women to be in a
position like that and they chose to go
with her some people told me sit there
and she's not as good of a leader they
just kind of did it as a publicity stun
because of all the metoo movement stuff
there's so many different stories look
at the end of the day if she's number
one a mediaite there's a reason for it
right this girl that was interviewing uh
what he called it Trump uh Caitlyn
Caitlyn Collins right Caitlin Collins
lover hater guess what she got a couple
billion views for the rest of her life
those videos are going to be shown with
her standing next to Trump oh yeah a 31
year old girl you can say whatever you
want to say about her I'm not
necessarily a fan of hers but I think
for her that's gonna stick around
forever now did he Punk her yes did he
troll her yes did the audience turn
against her yes did Trump pretty much
get everything he wanted out of this yes
but is a 31 year old still sitting there
debating with a president and getting
her you know score to go up sure she's
seen that increased her value that at
least doubled what her what she's worth
whether people she was making 2 million
now she's worth four you know she was
making three she's a six or not because
that's how this thing works how many
eyeballs do you get right no doubt do
you agree yeah I totally agree she's
totally agree we talked about the
winners and the losers from the the
Trump uh town hall and we said that
Trump was the big winner because he went
into enemy territory and held his own
and showed that he still has it CNN
Chris Licht you know he's taking a lot
of heat but I think they were a big
winner from there basically showing that
they can they can host Trump uh but I
think at the end of the day she was a
massive winner from all this she was not
a household name prior to this she would
host the morning show I think she
actually she worked for Tucker for Fox
at one point and now we're talking about
her so she's clearly the new Superstar
on CNN and they just gave her Don
lemon's old time slot so that's what
she's on at 8pm that was announced that
they were going to offer her the time
slot immediately following the town hall
with Trump there you go I mean but by
the way good for Siena and I actually
think I'm telling you I think Chris
Licht is is doing certain things right I
I know he's not getting enough credit I
think there are certain things he's
doing where he's showing signs of being
a capitalist and actually doing his job
instead of being a you know a uh uh just
succumbing to whatever the whims of uh
what is ESG all this stuff I think
there's certain things Chris is going to
write Michael I got a question for you
so you know how I mean Mike's going to
be here in a minute so we'll maybe
transition into this topic as well
in in every space there is uh the the
power players that you see that you know
of on TV right
and then there's power players you don't
see that the people you think are Power
Players know who the real Power Player
is right it's kind of like the movie
American Gangster hey it's this guy it's
that guy now it's really Frank Lucas
right is the real Power Player behind
closer hey you know you look at uh it's
really now it's really this guy that's
you know following all this stuff from
Colombia hey and the mob world it's
really this now it's was there ever a
person that
the street thought was the power player
but behind closed doors in the mob the
person that really held it all together
that everybody feared was XYZ was that
that person in your world yes who was
that person that was Chin giganti Chin
was yes okay got it everybody thought it
was uh Tony Salerno who was the boss uh
but it was really chin he was the power
in all of New York at that time
and and you think there are chins in
every space
I think so yeah I do absolutely
that we don't know about that we don't
know about you think there's a chintu
Murdoch
well you know
that's kind of tough I mean who's going
to tell him what to do you know I don't
know about that really the older Murdoch
I'm talking not the young not the young
one no I'm yeah you think there's a chin
to sorrow so you think Soros is chin I
think Soros is chin but he's the
difference with chin chin didn't want
anybody know who he was Soros is out
there I mean what this guy does now I
don't think there's anybody pulling the
strings on him I think he's the guy got
it so no one's pulling the soul who is
the chin of the right
God who's the Sorrows of the right
that's hard to say Patrick
really
who do you think it is who's the who's
the chin of the right I mean Soros who's
out there you know it you see his impact
yeah he's having on this country
I don't know if you talk about from a
financial standpoint You could argue
that the Koch brothers were there before
Sheldon Adelson passed away possibly him
I mean these guys were given
multi-millions if not billions of
dollars now this is what a musk said
about Soros yesterday he said Soros
reminds me of Magneto
okay and then uh Brian responds back uh
if you can put show more because he goes
into it pretty and then Elon responds
back again he says fun fact Magneto's
experiences during the Holocaust as a
Survivor shape this perspective as well
as his depth and empathy sorrow Sorrows
also a holocaust Survivor gets attacked
non-stop for his good intentions with
some Americans think are bad merely
because they disagree with his political
affiliation then look at what musk
responds back with you assume they are
good intentions they are not he wants to
erode the very fabric of civilization
Soros hates Humanity anyways they go
back and forth on how he views uh Soros
yeah I'd be curious to know who who the
current Soros is on the right yeah but
you know you see the impact of Soros you
know I think it was 2010 when something
happened to the Supreme Court he didn't
get a good decision and he publicly
stated he said it's going to be my
mission to destroy America he said it he
said it publicly and you can see his in
influence all over the country is he is
destroying America he's taking a big
part in that I don't see that on the
right I don't see even the Koch brothers
okay financially they got but what is
their influence what are they doing that
you can see that's so influential I
don't see it I don't see that on the
right well I think on the left you can
see it I think without a doubt the chin
to use an example is by Far and Away
Donald Trump at this point and he's
pulling all the strings on the right I'm
not saying
behind the scenes I'm saying in front of
the camera Maga making the moves that no
you don't think that Donald Trump
controls the right these days no you
don't think so no no because the the DNA
of a chin isn't they're never on camera
Patrick I when I was in the gas business
I had uh you know when you're making
that kind of money on the street
everybody starts looking at you and I
had a little trouble with my boss with
Persico at the time and it was kind of
known nothing big but it was it was
brewing right well the chin sense for me
I'd never met him but he sends for me
and I go see him we're walking on
Houston Street messed up hair bathrobe
exactly like you know they portrayed him
and we're walking up and down and he
said you know I got all respect for your
father and somebody introduced me to him
that that spoke very well about me and
he said I heard you're having some
trouble with Percival a person who was
the boss of the Columbus I swell chin
it's okay he said if you got a problem
is you come over here and you be a
captain with me
now I'm saying to myself that's the boss
of a family he's talking about and I
said well you know it's junior he said
did you hear what I said I said anytime
you want you leave there you come over
here you're a captain in my family
and the way he said it to me I said
that's when I realized this guy really
is the power no doubt yeah yeah
yeah
I I think every industry has a chin
and I say I think the best chins don't
want you to know who the chin is the
ultimate chin right now in the world is
who who's the ultimate Schwab maybe
actually if you think about the ultimate
chin and and I know this is going to be
the Woody Thomas the ultimate not the
ultimate shame he's not the ultimate I'm
about to talk about but the ultimate Way
of being a chin today is uh the founder
of Bitcoin Satoshi nokomo nobody has a
clue who he is no but he's pulling the
strings you know he's he's uh it's it's
a DNA of somebody that you don't know
what the you know he just kind of dances
and things are getting done he's the
last phone call people make well do you
see that person on the right
I I speculate a couple names but I I
don't see somebody today and I think
quite frankly I think
that's not really good I don't think
it's really good because I think the
right chin is also able to be a
synergist and keep people together
because you think about what Soros is
doing Soros is helping the left I was
going to say I wish we had one on yeah
right I think Soros is a help in the
left uh I think you saw what happened
with musk yesterday with the story that
came out did you see the story that came
out with musk yesterday right after he
hires the NBC Universal lady uh uh uh
Linda I have a hard time saying her last
name your car you know yakari or Sarina
or something like that this report comes
out the document subpoena and Jeffrey
Epstein's lawsuit by U.S Virgin Islands
JP Morgan Chase
etc etc Tesla alphabet all these guys
they're you know the U.S Virgin Islands
as subpoena Tesla see Obama documents
and Slauson JPMorgan Chase helping
sexuals I mean Jeffrey Epson see see to
me now this right here
this this is when you know
you're not shin
musk is not chin no they want to ignore
all the names on the left that
associated with Epstein yeah but now
immediately to go after the most yeah
they they they want to
I don't know man I I uh
it's those weird phone calls that you
get you know the the whole weird phone
calls you get where they say hey
um uh just so you know I have XYZ on you
okay I have this on you don't forget we
have access to your computer and we know
what you watch we know your search
engine we know what you look at on your
phone
we remember remember that one time your
phone crashed it wasn't that your phone
crashed we got into your phone we've
been monitoring everybody been texting
with every Everybody you've been uh
dming with all the pictures you've sent
the couple Brett Favre type of texts
you've sent we have access to all your
Brett Favre tap attacks you know we have
these videos we have the and then all of
a sudden like what yes kind of like J Ed
groover type of stuff when the mob you
guys went up to him and hey here's what
we have on you with this cross-dresser
um I don't know I I think
uh I think the left has a chin I don't
think the right has a chin and if they
do have a chin we definitely don't know
who that chin is he's not a good one
well speaking of the left having a chin
a lot of people firmly firmly firmly
believe that Barack Obama is running
this country right A lot of people think
that he's the do you disagree Shadow
president right now do you disagree do
you I don't I mean to be honest with you
I wouldn't mind him maybe being in a
decision room
and Biden making a phone call to him
versus Biden just kind of sleepwalking
through these decisions I don't know
would you have a problem with Barack
Obama being in the room so to speak did
you see the Durham report yesterday did
you see who was in it tell me you didn't
say the report you didn't see the the
the it was another Durham report that
came out different direction this
podcast but we were here about to talk
about some friendly stuff and you decide
to take it this direction listen this is
what we shame on you Adam we're supposed
to talk about who's the greatest boxer
of all time we were supposed to talk
about he's on his way
I like that
uh Michael I think you were going to say
something
well you see we came out in the report
that Obama knew what was he was briefed
on everything that was going on in the
whole Mueller investigation he was
briefed he knew that Hillary Clinton
sent that set it up he knew everything
and kept enlight about it well you know
what's new they all lie but I mean while
he was out of office
no he was in office okay yes he was in
office
let me tell you something Obama
the disappointing thing for me about I
met Obama on a beach in Hawaii I don't
even know who he was I had seen him at
the Democratic Convention he gave a
brilliant strike crushed it amazing and
so I walked up to him you know we were
talking on the beach this was before you
know he was thinking about being a
candidate nice guy said wow I would have
actually I couldn't vote because I was a
felon but I would have voted for him
that's how inspired I was by that speech
and I said you know what this guy has
got a chance to really unite this
country a lot of divisiveness here first
black president great he was a total
failure in that regard he he divided
this country more than anybody up to
that point I believe
you know I really do and it was a total
disappointment and then look
there were all there's so many of them
are dishonest but uh is he running the
party I don't know about that I don't
know I mean I think it's just a lot of
his influence
but I also know from what you hear from
what I was told that him and uh Biden
don't get along he didn't like a he
didn't like Biden really yeah he didn't
like him this is what I heard and you
know there's a part of me that kind of
uh uh based on what Michael just said
right now is
if you're if you're Obama do you want uh
Biden to run again
I don't know let's just say you are
running things you want him to run again
do you you want somebody else to run
yeah you know I I don't think Obama even
Obama wouldn't want Biden
I mean Patrick this guy let me ask you a
question in your wildest imagination did
you ever believe that this country could
deteriorate so so quickly in two years
under anybody
I mean in my opinion well I mean listen
the goat was Jimmy Carter right yeah and
he eclipsed the coat I never thought
that was gonna happen I'm in America
because of the goat Jimmy Carter you
know Jimmy Carter what they did to Iran
Kissinger himself it was a mess right
you know the whole economic hit man
throwing a country uh it's people
against its ruler its leader without
there being a real reason the country
had Advanced the way it has for decades
uh more freedom for women you know they
had a say they had a voice marriage went
from being eight years old 13 years old
15 years old it was more becoming like
you know uh uh and then boom Carter
comes and does what he does there and
then Us's and shambles interest rates
you know gas prices oil and then you
thought nobody was gonna do it worse
than him then shows a guy named Joe
which by the way if you listen to Joe's
talks 20 years ago 30 years ago you're
like
this guy's funny he's Charming yeah he's
charismatic I actually like listening to
the way he would speak in the 80s 90s
now don't get me wrong of course uh I'm
aware of all the speeches that he
literally replicated or duplicated exact
words that were said by this person or
that person or this person from various
countries not even in the US but you're
like this guy's actually saying you can
represent right today seeing what's
going on with weaponization with the
economy with the way things are being
handled it's a little weird it's a
little weird we're gonna see what's
going to happen uh for you are you more
uh at a time like this you're seeing the
Santas coming out with different things
he's doing rumor has it he's about to
announce that he's going to be
he's going to be running in announcing
in the next I don't know week two weeks
to you know three weeks it's been said
it's been a couple weeks for a minute
but let's just say uh uh uh in the first
week of June or the last week of May
he'll announce what are your thoughts
right now the Santa's Trump where are
you at with that has anything changed
listen here's what I say and you know I
gotta people sometimes knock me because
you know my whole thing I talk about mob
stuff and I think Michael don't get into
politics and what I try to tell people
this is not politics these are issues
that are affecting your life the way
politicians are dealing with it they're
creating these issues but these are
issues that are affecting you know our
lives are very live so I try to tell you
it's not politics I'm interested in the
future of this country and my kids my
grandchildren your this is issues that
we need to talk about so when when you
look at Biden in that regard
I just can't believe you know the damage
that he's done to this country and
continues
you know and look if he was a good
Democrat
hey great you know he's doing the right
thing so getting back to Trump and
DeSantis I love DeSantis I I gotta say I
love what he's doing I love his boldness
I think all his moves were right and
when Trump was in office I thought his
policies were great his policies I
thought he didn't act presidential in so
many ways getting on Twitter and doing
things I really believe Patrick and
forget the conspiracy theories about the
you know the the fraud and the uh the
election
if he would have a year before all of
this he would have said you know what
I'm not going to argue with Nancy Pelosi
I'm not going to do this I'm not going
to stoop to that level I'm worried about
the people in this country I'm going to
continue to do the right thing for the
country and and get rid of all that
other stuff that he did all that
pettiness all that divisiveness that's
what killed him I understand he's a New
Yorker he fights back in his defense
I've never seen anybody get attacked
like that every single day of his life
getting boom boom I've never seen
anything like it and you know to his
credit he stood up to it he didn't fold
and he didn't he didn't go into the
pressure but the way he reacted it was
so divisive and people have had enough
even now you know the one thing about
the him on the CNN deal he acted more
present he tried to stay on the issues I
said wow maybe maybe there's you know
the the light went off in his head maybe
he's starting to realize forget all
those other nonsense tell people what
they need to hear what they want to hear
how you going to fix what's wrong in
this country
because that's what people are starving
to hear look you know they can say
whatever they say I you know I believe
the southern border I mean look you got
to be in you got to be
on drugs not to realize what's going on
he's bringing all these people in here
he's going to hope it's some way he
gives them a path to citizenship so they
can vote or at least vote and they want
to be in power forever that's it that's
it that's the total plan they're not
humanitarians they don't care about
these people coming in that's got to be
the plan and for people not to see that
I don't get it I really don't Patrick so
you know Trump DeSantis
okay if Trump were back in office his
policies would be good he would I think
he would do the right thing again I
really believe that he cares about this
country I mean that's what I see in him
aside from all the other clutter that's
around him he cares about this country
but I don't know if we can take that
again I don't know if we can take him in
office again so you would rather see the
Santos over Trump you know because I
think DeSantis his policies will be just
as good he'll do the right thing and
maybe less stuff that we have to listen
to unless the right I mean the left goes
after him in the same way I don't know
he doesn't have that kind of baggage it
seems that it that he can be attacked
like Trump was
but I think Michael brings up a really
good point uh about maybe the difference
between Trump and DeSantis you know A
wise man once said choose your enemies
wisely all right that would be a great
book title yeah be a great book title
coming out soon
um and I think Trump's problem was I
think Michael's absolutely right he was
attacked viciously by the left and some
of it was warranted some of it was
unwarranted some of it was Trump
drainsman syndrome
the problem with Trump is everyone was
his enemy like you know how they say
don't punch down punch up right he would
pick a fight with everybody like no
matter what he would punch him 10 times
harder and 99 of the time he should not
even respond to somebody's Twitter folks
or just any just media Outlet anything
just don't even give them the time of
day
but he would and he would engage in
these little battles with people that
were completely beneath him whereas
DeSantis uh maybe he had a a little
preview of that book that that might be
coming out soon and he's choosing his
enemies very wisely whether it's Disney
whether it's the woke Florida is where
woke comes to die whether it's the
abortion issue he's picking and choosing
his battles but I love this one response
when Trump was banging on him and
somebody said what do you think about
Trump anger he says I'm not a candidate
right that was it
but just perfect correct he's he's
living to the fullest what we're talking
about right now he's like he knows it
doesn't make sense at this point no to
start engaging in a battle with Trump
yet at some point he's gonna probably
have to step up to the podium to do that
if you want to hopefully he'll do it
intelligently and he won't get into the
the real dirt the way Trump does I mean
that's that's not good for anybody it
wears you out it wears you was that your
biggest problem with Trump not the
policies it was just the personality and
then going down that rabbit hole of of
nonsensical stuff I I cannot believe
some of the you know criticisms that
people have about Trump and I tell him
listen you know in a way president it is
a personality contest you want to see
somebody that's charismatic and has a
personality but it's really about his
policies and how he deals with America
and I still it's not personal I'm not
going to have you know Trump go out with
my daughter I don't invite him over for
dinner but his policies were good for
America you know so what else are you
looking at what do you care about what
he didn't personal life I mean yeah you
know now I mean you know the CNN you
know some of the the uh criticism of him
while he's you know he's a sexual abuser
and he's this he had how could you have
him on television well he's running for
president what do you mean you know
that's when you realize is CNN really a
news organization anymore
because the people within CNN are
knocking them meanwhile they had the
highest ratings they had in how long why
wouldn't you put them on the air you
know who's calling Trump's Camp right
now MSNBC
then NBC from the top is saying you guys
better not do this this is not worth it
don't give them the eyeballs MSM is like
[__] we need some Raiders
absolutely also as well and then and
then you know it's probably going to end
up being last it's going to be fox fox
is going to be end up being less on a
Town Hall he's going to do a town hall
with everybody look how he works look
how he works these are the things that
you have to give credit to Fox doesn't
want to do a town hall he says no
problem who's your number one enemy CNN
and I'm gonna go to a town hall with
them then MSNBC then you're going to
call me and say while we're not doing a
tunnel because all the fox viewers are
going to ask you how come you're not
doing McDonald's your fans your viewers
who pay the money are going to force you
to do a town hall and it's going to be
on my term so I'll be patient in the
next six months you'll host a town hall
for me except it's going to be on my
terms this is the kind of stuff that you
want a guy like that that's negotiating
with Putin with G with zelinski with
this with that you want you want that
you don't want somebody that's going and
saying whose ice cream is better Russia
or China you know you want somebody
that's wanting to really figure out ways
to use power plays
the world you're in one of the things uh
uh when the first time you and I sat
there and you had written a book and uh
make you an offer I can make you know if
you can't read first of all it's every
businessman we're not here to promote
his book trust me that's not the reason
for why it's here this is just a thing
if you're if you run a business and
you're running a company just on the
side put the link below do yourself a
favor go buy this book I think after the
when I we talked about it we saw like a
hundred thousand copies I don't know
what happened put the link below I'm
telling you if you're in business go
read this book I think it's only 140
Pages 150 Pages if you go to the bottom
how many pages is it it's the most use
it's the best use 155 Pages read do
yourself a favor
in the business World take all the stuff
that you guys did illegally though all
the other stuff take the murder take
that out
man that's you know you know there's a
lot of the stuff that you you talk about
in this book is stuff that you got to
have if you're gonna run for office the
gamesmanship that the enemy is going to
use against you the manipulation the
opponent is going to use against you how
do you deal with that how do you manage
that how do you work with that how do
you still go out and get a deal how do
you negotiate how do you not go in a
room without any kind of Leverage to
negotiate and still find a leverage how
do you go and when you have all the
leverage in the world and you can
destroy the person and figure out a way
to make them an ally how do you there's
so many different things there to use
um I think that's the part that you
can't teach somebody to do and it seems
like he's got a bit of it so if if he
does get reelected man it's going to be
well America is going to lose their
minds if he gets reelected well Patrick
let's let's get through something that's
to me the most serious issue that we're
facing right now this whole
investigation with him and his family
yes
let me tell you something I had 18 llc's
Panamanian companies 18 of them
all of none of them had a business
we're just a company that I needed to
open up a bank account that was it okay
we were washing my shell companies okay
I am telling you this is a racketeering
indictment waiting to happen there's no
question about it
there's no there's no function to any
one of these companies he's funneling
money through different the same way I
did it 100 exactly the way I did it and
with me I'm just taking money from the
government all right I'm stealing tax
money okay I went to jail for that but
this guy is influence pedaling does what
else could it be Patrick when people
open their eyes and just look at it what
else can it be reporters have the nerve
to say well we can't track any money
they went directly to Biden so what so
what did it didn't go to him it went to
his family
even if he didn't get a penny and went
to his family he did it for to to
benefit the Biden family this is and
then you know I'm saying to him people
have brought this out you know we got a
Chinese balloon flying over the country
taking all these surveillance you know
classified information that we have this
guy's backing down every which way I
mean this is dangerous stuff for America
yeah you know what's going to happen
Michael this is what I think is going to
happen
I think they're going to protect him
Tony Michelle he is no longer needed
then he will be a useful idiot and then
they'll destroy him and they'll all turn
on him and they'll all tell the stories
about how bad he was and what he'll
they'll they'll do to him what they did
to Andrew Cuomo that's how quickly
they'll flip on the guy once they cannot
use him anymore because right now you
know they don't want him to run and he's
being punished Stephanie rule is her
name is that her name of course you know
America doesn't want you to run in other
words like there's no Fortune 500
company right now that's trying to
recruit a CEO that's 82 years old that's
going to be 86 at the end of their terms
what makes you think you're qualified to
do this experience
this that watch me no watch me so but
the but the point is Democrats don't
want this guy right so if he goes
against Democrats and he still runs the
moment they're able to get rid of them
whatever way they do they're going to
turn on him like this in no time he's
not Bill Clinton they'll turn on in in
no time
and they'll they'll then share the
stories of yeah well you know all these
investigations nobody knew and then all
of a sudden the truth came out and was
you know somebody like this and you know
same thing they did to Cuomo Andrew
Cuomo was supposed to be the next
president at one point yeah everybody in
America is like yeah he looks more
presidential than Donald Trump does look
at the way he does his meanings every
day in New York and the next thing you
know
um no he doesn't want to negotiate and
work with us throw him under the bus
let's replace him very quickly like this
it happened but Patrick how far has
America sunk when you have a president
that uh that basically might have sold
out the country and people are
protecting him from that the news media
is protecting him from that you know
where do you draw the line and say wait
a second you know I live here I have
kids here it is my home this guy is
selling secrets to the foreign
government you know or influence
peddling when do you draw the line as as
America look
you look at every major major power you
know throughout history why were they
destroyed immorality
finances and the military going to hell
and and things are happening like that
in this country you know with these
great Powers they always they always
crumble from within first
you know
and I just can't understand look I was a
mob guy okay I was on the street
I don't know guys on the street that
would do what this guy is doing and what
the left is doing I don't get it
you know what are they trying to
accomplish is it all I say well you know
I get it it's all about money and power
they want to stay in power okay but you
want to destroy the country while you're
staying in power what power are you
going to have at that point I don't know
I mean I I in my lifetime I never
thought I'd ever see a situation like we
have right now look the FBI always knew
they were corrupt but what were you
seeing now we saw on the Mueller report
you know how they went along with all of
this how they instigated how they
covered things up I always knew that but
people would say oh you you guys are
criminals on the street okay all right
so they they pushed the envelope with us
okay you know maybe you can justify it
even though I say this whenever you give
the government power and allow them to
break the law in order to get the law
Breakers it's going to turn on you at
someday and that's exactly what's
happening okay exactly what's happening
but to I never thought I would see it
deteriorate to this degree I mean we're
in a lot of trouble I'm a very
optimistic guy my wife gets crazy at me
God don't worry about it no problem
we'll fix it everything's okay
I'm pessimistic about the direction of
America I don't know if we can be fixed
at this point other than the order
Michael what do you think the biggest
issues are facing the country right now
if if what you're saying is true that
you've never seen the country like this
and Biden's doing the worst job you've
ever seen the Border clearly a mess
right with title 42 just uh expired as
that yeah what else would you put in the
top of the list these days listen I I
don't think this is a racist country I
think they're trying to divide us in a
way that I've never seen before this is
not a racist country not at all you know
not at all huge problem the divisiveness
in the country and you know it starts
from the top and it trickles down and
that's all you hear this inclusiveness
listen you want the best people in
office you don't want to people in
office because there are different race
a religion a Creed or background you
want the best people there to do the job
you know and now I mean because of
inclusiveness the they're trying to make
you know America look like the League of
Nations okay we agree with that you can
you can Patrick you know this you can
succeed in this country no matter what
all right maybe some people have a
little you know they they came up the
different way they didn't have the
advantages they didn't have you know uh
the advantages that some other people
have but you can still overcome that in
America
this is a great country great country
but what they're doing here and it's all
about money and power they want to stay
in power that's why I think I can't
think of any other reason why he has
opened up the southern border like this
when they try to get them the ability to
vote what are they going to tell them
hey you vote for Republicans they're
sending out of here you got to stay with
us
that's it
if Texas turns blue you'll never see
another Republican in office never
another Republican in office you got
Florida I mean you got New York you got
Texas you got California yeah
standpoint it's going to be very hard to
win if you don't have Texas and that's
what they're trying to do
and they keep saying that you keep
seeing a slow drip where you know they
keep saying this is the year that that
Texas is turning blue this is the year
the text is turning blue but I still I
still think there's a five-point margin
of Victory but it's it used to be double
digits and uh you I think you're
absolutely right you lose Texas then
you never know what will happen in these
elections I want to tell you this you
know we're going I know we're jumping
around but if this were anybody at this
table or anybody else that were doing
when Hunter Biden they would have been
in jail a long time ago it would have
been over
done the evidence is there it's like a
you know it's like the the Republicans
said the other day I'm giving you this
case on a you know on a silver platter
it's all here you don't have to do
anything we did it for you
they still don't want to touch it
this is bad stuff but
so you know so you know what that does
though uh remember this scene where uh
uh because you'd be in jail you know
which line I'm talking about because
you'd be in jail you know Trump and
Hillary are so great that a man like you
is not in the office because you know
because you'd be in jail okay so a lot
of people were thinking when he does get
elected that's gonna happen Hillary's
gonna be held accountable didn't happen
and and he didn't drain the swamp that's
a bit of a criticism that he gets from
some of the people that actually
supported the guy but you know the next
person that gets elected one of the
things is hey we're gonna go in we're
actually gonna drain the swamp we're
gonna find out who's behind us and we're
gonna investigate it okay so
then there's going to come a moment
where that person's close and everyone
knows that guy's going to be a president
then he's going to get a phone call
and he's going to say you as a sitting
president cannot undermine the previous
president especially investigate him
it's going to be a very bad look for you
to get reelected then they're going to
somehow someway create other boogie man
in you know so forget about the real
investigation and then four years going
to go by and then never happens so what
are the chances that FBI will eventually
investigate these guys
they never seem to hold anybody
accountable on the left I mean nobody
falls down for anything I mean look
Hillary Clinton smashes her computer I
mean look I I can't tell you you know
I've had experience with this you know I
had records missing and they wanted to
hang me for it you know if they could
have you're smashing up your your your
your your phones your computers that
have you know information on there that
can be harmful to you nothing happens
I mean maybe she was pissed at Bill
Clinton maybe Bill Clinton send a text
and you know and Bill did something in
that computer you know what's her excuse
going to be for destroying the computer
I mean actually think about it right
yeah can you imagine the average person
is like so why'd you shatter the
computer you know what it fell out of my
hands okay why else could it be I was
just upset at bill because Bill did this
the the average person is going to sit
there and say what were you hiding in
that thing okay should the American
people know or no who knows anyways
that's why we bring our uh political
analyst the great Mike Tyson in the
house
come on in
man sir
Adam you want to pull up your chair yes
sir
after you Mr Tyson I'll do good to see
you Mike if you feel like knocking
anybody out the guy in the green shirt
that's what we would all love to see
we're allies I don't have to worry
you're safe
so how was cardio
yeah it's good yeah yeah great so we
we've been
we've been talking a lot of different
things but uh you know the the the the
idea of you you guys teaming up to do
something sounds very exciting you know
the the project you guys have going on
is exciting to see uh it's called what
Champions Corner yeah yeah you want to
kind of tell the audience a little bit
about it well pretty much it's going to
be about um
as you know people that experience life
like me and Mike and we'll talk about
pretty much mentorships and what
mentorship meant to us and what it when
it and what it's going to mean to our
future without mentorship pretty much
here
you're gonna be finished you're not
going to be of any kind of use without
without mentorship me myself
um
if I describe myself I would describe
myself as just the worst of the worst
this is the bottom of the bat
um had no idea I had no intentions of
having a healthy good future and then I
met this old Italian man and cussed
their motto and they changed my whole
way of thinking and it wasn't for him if
it wasn't for him I wouldn't be here
talking to you guys he made me believe
that was the greatest ever lived Mike
who else was it outside of him did you
have a couple men like that in your life
that played a big role hey nobody plays
the bigger role in him wow like the
differentiator it's not even close no
not even [__] please close don't even
they're not in the same race wow you
don't he's just on the field by himself
one of one of my favorite things we
talked about last time was about your
relationship with cuss and you know the
two of you the reason why I'm excited
about this project you guys have is
because the background to go from there
you know and to experience what you've
experienced in your life both of you
both of you are also New York so you
know it doesn't get rougher than the
streets you guys came up to be be where
you are today Mike how important of a
role does a man a strong man play in a
boy's life when he's trying to find
himself well um you know you have to
think about what perception of the
strong man he could be a strong man and
a criminalist perspective in the legal
perspective and that could be the
strongest identity that he sees and so
he can go off in that level of crime as
well but it's all about um and when I
say that
even if people in crime they're great
men I won't say they're all good men but
they're great men and so um if we could
really concentrate on doing the best we
can from our perspective of being a good
man and transforming that into other
children other young boys that will be a
start Michael you're seeing right now
messages on YouTube go viral where it's
grown man like Jordan Peterson talk
about what it is to be a man or even
Andrew Tates talking to young boys there
seems to be a you know in every industry
there's a sect of that industry does
very well like hey in books young
non-fiction is doing really well right
now really youth nonfiction yes kids
want to know more okay interesting you
know in the denomination of religion hey
the LDS church has grown at the space
right now really why what are they doing
hey when it comes down to Content being
created right now young boys want to
learn from a man with experience maybe
they don't have a father figure growing
up why do you think that content is
resonating the way it is with young boys
because of the fact that you know
there's a there's an effort to demean
what a real man is today if I see it
that way anyhow you know and when people
look up to a guy that presents himself
like a man then it's attractive to them
you know look one of the reasons Patrick
I go into prisoners I talk to these
young gang bangers you know and they'll
say to me come on Michael you had the
great cause you had the women you know
you you wore the right clothing to them
that's what a man looks like so they
want the image of a man you know a
manhood but you know the problem is a
lot of people today think that when
you're telling a man how to be a man
that it's demeaning to a woman they've
they've made that a part of of uh
Society now well if you're telling this
guy to be a man that means it's a good
demean women and I said no a real man is
going to benefit women women are going
to benefit by that because you're going
to treat her the right way you know he's
going to bring up his kids properly he's
gonna you know he's going to be in the
community do the right thing that's what
a man is it's not you know being a macho
guy or anything like that of course you
gotta defend yourself man protects his
women of course
but you know there's just the the idea
of a man has been changed today it
really has and and that's what we uh we
want to teach guys oh look a man can be
sensitive a man can have emotion you
know there's nothing wrong with that you
know how many times look I want to what
the most powerful guys you want to see I
see him crying at a funeral they go to a
a show and they got tears in their eyes
on an opera show I've seen that there's
nothing wrong with that you're showing
emotion you know it's
you know and I think these young guys
today are really looking for that yeah
you know and they look they look at
somebody like Mike who let me tell you
something you know the way he came up
and to be where he is today it's a
miracle it really is you know under the
odds that he had to face in that way you
know mine is different I didn't go
through the some of the things that he
wanted it was different for me but uh
you know the fact that I'm here you know
this Patrick I should be dead or in
prison a long time ago it's just been
very fortunate you know so we want to
use these experiences to try to help
people and and that's what this is all
about and uh and we're going to do it I
fully agree with what Michael's saying
is that there's just such a need for
leadership uh for young men these days I
guess my question is
it's not a zero-sum game like for
forever we've heard that it's the
patriarchy and this is this is basically
has given a rise to modern day feminism
and then you see things like the future
is female where it's like what is that
if the future is female what does that
mean for men right and then you see
things like the feminism and the boss
babe movement and everything with that
it's men and women can both win right I
think women want a strong man in their
life and men want a you know what's the
famous phrase behind every great man
there's a strong woman so how can men
and women win it in today's society what
do you think well listen that's gonna be
pretty difficult
because when you watch television you
see it could be black people could be
white it's confrontation between man and
woman that's what you see on television
that's what you see on housewives show
that's just what you see you see this on
um Kevin Samuel you show you you see
this on sometimes what's the other guy
Andrew take it's just confrontation
confrontation cells and we're not gonna
stop this conversation this is gonna be
coming error so we can continue to make
money off of people's pain so whether
it's Republicans Or democrats whether
it's blacks and whites whether it's men
and women it's just going to constantly
be doubling down on this against each
other if you want to see the future of a
country look at his advertisement
what does it advertise damn you know
what that makes me think of right so
about how we're the only existence
you just made two profound comments in
the last minute what about you know how
United States and I think New Zealand
are the only countries that big Pharma
is allowed to advertise on so when you
see the opioid uh endemic that's going
on right now I think Mike Tyson makes up
a great point it's that if you want to
see the future of a country look at the
advertising how many people are on big
families now look at the MC family
before like taboos to mix a black or
Italian a black Asian Spanish that was
taboo you think but now it's promoting
this is what it's going to be because if
you see the influx of different um I'm
not gonna immigrants immigrants coming
in the country and that and they're
showing you this is what it's going to
look at and they're preparing us they
put in the televisions or movies you
know and that's what we're preparing for
because people know the society knows
that run the place
um Americans black white Asians they
don't take kindly to immigrants we just
don't I don't know why because when the
Irish was here like in the 1800s and
when Irish they were called Real
Americans but when the Irish came from
Ireland they crushed them
they made them the enemy how could you
do that that means if I came out they
made these guys the enemy
for they could take advantage to them
and Rob them so they made these guys you
don't have to have any feelings someone
like slaves yeah
we have human nature what other
advertisements you see on TV that are
shocking to you like that's a profound
statement you said if you want to see a
future for Country look at the
advertising what else do you see on TV
well some things I rather than not talk
about okay you know that um it's you
know it's just interesting you know um
it's just what it is I guess
Mike your kids that go to private or
public I have one kid that goes to
public
Heritage here and I have won this online
school yeah he was yeah online yeah
what's your thoughts in the public
versus private
and um
Public School
you get the diversity you get everything
coming at you the good the bad the
bullies the tough guys the Geeks it's
all just coming at you and you have a um
you have an opportunity to choose what
you're going to do in a private school
boom everybody's in the same line every
day is the same way no one nobody nobody
gets off the fence we all stay on the
fence in um private school and then
publicly on the fence you get off the
fence and you make mistakes
you know most of the private schools
they prevent them the best way possible
we're going to make mistakes but the
best way possible they prevent them from
making mistakes and being discouraged
who would who would Mike Tyson have been
if he went to private school
Mike typhen yeah who who would he have
been if he would have gone to private
school
I don't know
not what I am now not what you are now
yeah it wasn't meant for me I would I
probably would uh I probably would have
been snob if I want to pop up you think
so you think that would have been the
case uh I got a little bit of that stuff
in me
[Laughter]
literally I think zero brings up an
amazing point because I went to public
school K through 10 in my last couple
years I I got a scholarship a sports
scholarship to go to private school but
I think it was the public school
mentality the bullies that they don't
hang out with that guy watch your back
over here that really shapes you who you
are exactly so I know that you're a huge
advocate for private school but you're a
public school kid 1.8 GPA
what obviously there's so many benefits
going to private school the network the
status the education everything with
that what are the concerns you have with
private school though when you hear
someone like Mike Tyson say yeah it
wouldn't make me the man I am today I've
never gone to private I've gone to
public right so to me when you go to
public you see everything you see gangs
drugs cocaine pot you know the nurse the
athletes the you know these guys those
guys valedictorian you see it all
there's an advantage to it as well but
my concern is I'm 44 today so I went to
school today your birthday no no I'm 44
years old but uh could you imagine your
birthday is next month all right June
23rd 30th June 30th yeah so I'm a
October 18th baby 1978 so Scorpio over
there I'm gonna Libra your cancer right
yeah yeah cancer is our beasts so
um
so 1996 was when I graduated this was
the whole Tupac you know the the only
like the devastating day for me was that
they were in La I'm going to Glendale
High School but
when I was going to High School versus
what I'm seeing today
it's not the same like my my high school
today a bunch of people from Glendale
Unified School District have messaged me
they've created an Instagram account of
what's going on right now gusd okay how
they're letting uh boys go into girls
bathroom and all this other stuff
it's not the public school we went to
there was none of that when I went to
the girls bathroom I got suspended
hit me in the face or something ran in
the bathroom yeah Mike said when he was
when he was younger girls bullied him
not bad yeah kicked my ass bit me and oh
[__] it's because they liked you Mike I
bet
but your kids being in private school
today well I mean again for me like if
I'm if I'm gonna go on Champions corner
and I want to you know what I want to
learn I want to learn from their
mistakes their wisdom their parents now
they have they have the ability to go
from teens to 20s to 30s to 40s to 50s
there's different desires and
temptations and things that you go
through in every age I want to learn
from it by the way how many people like
if you look at Mike Tyson's life okay
how many people's combined life
experience equals Mike Tyson's hey no
but listen oh man I'm just like you you
don't think I'm scared of those public
schools for my kids because I experience
that stuff you don't think I think I
want somebody to do some lie asking my
kids faith
no but um
if they didn't have that opportunity I
would want them to be in public school
you know we were struggling for the
money that no we want them to go and
experience that you have to expand I
want my kids to experience where I lived
at I wanted to take them to Brownfield
Brooklyn let me pizza you know let them
go to the gather them this guy is your
father I don't know that little kid
that's your father
and wow and you did that oh absolutely
what was the reaction when they saw it
scared to death didn't want to get
involved it was the apartment that
pretty condemned but with a hole in in
the uh
the door I thought peeping if they
didn't know I'm not Peters in there and
I said look at this man it's just um a
concrete jungle Concrete Jungle and
these guys are um wow these guys are
animals describe the human beings
that's just what it is Mike do you think
do you think the
record the Killer Instinct concept right
you know certain people have a Killer
Instinct then you'll see them like you
you know Celtics beat the Sixers right
and you've seen all the fans over there
you're seeing all the Sixers fans and
you're seeing who the Sixers fan who the
Celtics fans are they're like these guys
are dogs right like you can tell they're
tough guys right New York DNA right yes
you see certain people like there's a
certain level of toughness and
ruggedness and fearlessness right that
comes from it do you think the the
Killer Instinct folks in business in
politics in sports do you think they
need a little bit of that craziness
experience to go through or not
necessarily in all cases it depends on
the consequences that you're willing to
accept
what do you mean by that you know by
having that Killer Instinct the title
wanting one and one there's
repercussions to that
you know there's lawsuits there's people
that want to ruin your career they might
want to hurt your family you know it's a
lot of people
um percussions that come with being the
dog the Beast animal the universe tests
you
did you did you watch the are you into
movies or no do you like kind of have
you watched the new movie air the story
of Michael Jordan they keep telling me
to look at that you've got to watch it
Ben Affleck no I watch it I watch it
have you seen it yet or no I haven't
seen it was up the ball Mike you gotta
watch it because there's a scene in the
movie
were Sunny so we took 60 of our
employees here and we took 150 of our
insurance agents in Dallas and I want to
watch I watched it three times in two
weeks it's an incredible movie there's a
scene in the movie where Sonny is
sitting there talking to Michael okay
it's when Nike's making the pitch to
Michael to come to us and Michael
doesn't want to go to Nike he wants to
go to Adidas and he wants to go to all
these things
and he's saying Michael I'm just going
to get right into it he says look no
one's going to remember us they're going
to remember you he says we're all just
people in your life but long term here's
what's going to happen to you here's
what America is good at you're going to
go up there you're going to win you're
going to win a lot of championships
you're going to win MVPs you're going to
do this you're going to do that but then
the media is going to turn on you
there's going to be some losses there's
going to be some setbacks and he's while
he's explaining this he shows when his
dad dies in the movie they show when
he's losing they show when he's in the
Chicago White Sox and he's missing the
ball they show all of these things where
the the idea my dad told me this when I
was 16 years old says one thing about
America you know as an immigrant this
guy my dad's wisdoms you'll meet him
today when we're having lunch you you'll
need my dad so he said in America this
is what they'll do he says if they want
to turn you into a hero they'll turn you
into a hero but if they want to turn you
to see you fall America loves a fall but
what America even loves more than a fall
is redemption and a comeback it's such
an interesting thing about America what
happens to the great one so you know a
story like yours when you're talking
about the consequences you're willing to
face
um it's an interesting perspective when
you think about it Tom Brady do you you
see a Killer Instinct than a guy like
that right but he was raised in a
good family environment right you if you
watch man in the arena mom dad you know
three older sisters
you wonder like is the Killer Instinct
DNA is the Killer Instinct life
experiences is The Killers it's the
choice there's this thing that you say
that because
um
we know some athletes that's number one
and probably the best in the world in
Europe their families are billionaires
but their families can't buy that spot
I'm being the best they can't buy
so it's not money it's the desire to win
it's so it's the individual Europe yeah
normally when people
um are siblings or people that wealthy
they want to differ they want to um
pretty much
I'm spit from them they want their own
identity then sometimes they change
their names because they want their own
identity they have their own self-worth
how about Mike I want to stay on this
too to just ask this question from him
when he became the youngest heavyweight
okay
and we're all watching look oh my God
you know they called it cuss called it
these ones because I guess heavyweight
everybody's losing their minds right 20
20 years old 21 years old youngest ever
heavyweight champion
did that automatically attract other
goats that wanted to be around you who
were the champions and if it did which
I'm assuming it did because we've seen
pictures with you pretty much with
everybody
did you notice a similarity between your
wife where you're like oh I see I see
Michael oh I see magic oh I see Gretzky
oh I see Ali or ice man I kind of see a
little bit of myself and very
interesting how we have these two three
things in common did you see that
yourself or you weren't looking at it
from that lens no because
I really look at it not from a um if I'm
if I'm able to be permitted to say I
just think that people from that
perspective it's just ordained by God
that happened like that and it's not
necessarily because we're athletes and
entertainers there are people who are
the um pretty much
ordained by God to be the greatest
businessman to be the greatest garbage
man it's just it's all from the universe
and we have nothing to do with it but
just putting in the effort
interesting so it's a form of a
you know being chosen or being called
type of a thing pretty much I think I
think because custody summoned me
you know I'm I'ma meet this old Italian
guy
foreign
wow you know Patrick most guys from the
street that came up the hard way they
fold not many guys make no no you know
you it's something within you that makes
you overcome that you got to have a
drive a determination because most guys
that come up like that they're gone
a mentor a great mentor I had a good the
best mentor and the plan that is nobody
could do just do to me what he could
nobody could never know when he was the
greatest nobody can make me reach the
path
do you in your house or your office or
you know do you have a picture of them
absolutely what's your favorite picture
of you and him
um me hugging them after a fight or is
it is it no yes for taking a picture so
it's a it's a picture you have we
haven't seen so it's not a public
picture I'm sure the thing yeah got him
that's cool to you know it's
uh uh which one is that do you see it is
that the one on the right in front of
the white building no we'll go back I
saw it if you could yeah it was that day
it's that day no more probably go back
it just you had it go back it's to fart
fart to the right all the way to the
right right there up oh I hate being
there it is that one right there and
he's like get that off me he hates it
man what are you doing get off that's
your favorite picture yeah it's like get
off stop he doesn't like intimacy he
doesn't like that stuff he's too hard
what do you think about when you see
that picture
um he was right I'm the greatest ever
wow
he was right
you bring up the Tom Brady thing and
yeah obviously Tom Brady and Mike Tyson
had a complete differing upbringing not
even a question
um but one thing they did have was a
chip on their shoulders so you bring up
Tom Brady drafted in the seventh round
189th pick you see the picture of when
he was drafted he didn't even look he
looked like he was just some frat dude
his sister's with a good athlete exactly
right so put a chip on his shoulder if
you look at MJ the you know as The Story
Goes cut from his high school basketball
team holy [__] that just basically wound
him up he turned it look at Kobe when
you interviewed Kobe what happened with
Kobe he was number 40 something on the
top 100 list of uh high school
basketball players boom he developed a
kill list so it's yeah there's the
picture of Tom Brady doesn't look like
the goat right there does he no turned
out to be the greatest quarterback to
ever live
there has to be some even with you with
business when you went to the Army and
they told you that you would never be
nothing in your life your teachers you
got a 1.8 GPA you developed a chip on
your shoulder that said all right I'm
gonna turn this thing around so Mike
what was it for you I I completely
understand that cost was your uh is your
motivation everything that but you must
have had a chip on your shoulder what
was it that basically inspired you to
say all right let me turn my life around
and make this happen oh no I even know
this in order to be at math the first
have to be a fool and then after that it
works out
you first have to be a fool yeah okay
yeah what does that mean
make mistakes and don't get um
discouraged it's so easy to get
discouraged and give up yeah
this is kind of what Mike yeah I've been
knocked out before the average I had
nothing came easy for me I didn't give
up
remember like how old were you for
somebody got knocked out like actually
knocked out I went with a little kid
how old I don't know 11 11 years old
yeah who was the guy oh he hit me with a
bat
they don't know our world he'll be in a
I got hit by a club remember the club in
the in the cars the clubs used to put to
steering wheels
18 years old in Kentucky I'm like damn I
thought somebody get hit with that too
split this thing too I broke my nose I
woke up four o'clock in the morning is
that is that what happened that's one of
the ways that one of the broken my nose
a few times he had to break that up was
actually it was old school way it's
before we had uh the current alarm stuff
I'll never forget the story when you
guys did the interview at the MGM inside
the uh the ring literally and you were
talking about one of the first times
that Mike I don't know if this was one
of the first but when you really knew
that you had powered you talked about
that you fought the kid and then the
father showed up yeah you're fighting
the Father tell us that so how old were
you when you're fighting grown men
um
I was like 11 12. that was big you know
I mean I'm like 11 years old by the
month 175 pounds at 11. yeah 160 so so
um
I'm short though so I'm fighting the guy
I don't know if I'm fighting because I'm
taking so I'm trying to take something
for him that mostly that happens when
you're fighting him and his family so
I'm trying to take some maybe it's
jacket or his watch something I'm trying
to take I'm just I'm trifling like that
back then and then I I was fighting with
him and I don't know if I snatched this
code off but his father came running
down the street and when he was on the
floor as far as came and he started to
try to throw I picked him up slammed
them on the floor
and um
the kid jumped on me from behind yeah
you know I kicked the ass but they
kicked my ass too you know father-son
dude they got me good though they got me
good has that ever been uh uh they got
they became my close friends too how did
that happen I don't know that's what
happened you understand you fight your
friends to the death of me try to Rob
them and then as time goes on you guys
become friendly you guys Rob other
people right absolutely
is that is that what happened with you
in Evander Holyfield you guys are
friends now I think you guys are working
in business yes yes yes yes yes I mean I
was um bust this chapter me and you're
the only people still making money from
a fight that happened 30 years ago
straight up right that's right yeah how
did that friendship develop because at
one point you guys were as competitive
enemies as it gets right we've always
been I knew him since I was 17 years old
you know from the boxing scene and um
I had made these ears
um when you pull up at your company that
they launched
holy bites yes and um show a picture of
it the product if you can rob Mike Tyson
asked you to show a picture buddy there
goes right there the ear and um
they would go enough the hook and he was
a little offended he was a little
offended at first and then he and then
he ended up time why are you doing this
to me man
he's a little offended to me so the
prophet of it he said that Prophet hey
I'm with you
Mike bites he was like you might have
taken oh you're 30 already
yeah listen guys I can I really ask you
a question what how if I um
I'm trying to think the word
satanic
people are so happy yeah
we have families we live in a country of
savages you know that right first of all
first time I saw it I'm like what what
should the fight if you watched them did
you watch the fight live or no live no I
mean I wasn't there but I was seven
years old yeah you're seeing it you're
like oh you were at the actual fight yes
me and uh Chuck Zito and Stallone we're
all there that night
what uh what was the reaction did how
long did it take for the audience to
know what happened oh it was crazy yeah
I I don't think I didn't know right away
what happened didn't understand it but
then we were hearing things you know
because I was in like the third or
fourth row we're hearing things and then
then obviously everybody knew after that
but
yeah what happened afterwards though you
know I was with I was with my wife too
and the place went crazy afterwards I
told her we're not leaving here just sit
here until everybody leaves and
everything gets calmed down but that was
crazy I know the word without Mike it's
crazy huh you you said you made 30
million dollars I think you said this
last year sometime in October you made
30 million dollars from this fight just
from the bite well after I know I made
27 because they took three for me
finding me three luck
they find you for three million for
there you go you said I got fined three
million dollars for that uh yeah and I
might have made 30 million dollars since
that happened from the bite for me yeah
the bite hurt
no from Jeff um the mic bite every time
I'm doing a signing and they take a
picture of biting people's ears all over
the world take a picture
what what the hell then you got white
supremise bite my ear
you made it if it's that listen stop
serial killer bite my ear bite my ear
listen I'll um
let me say this one story I'm in Phoenix
I'm working out in Phoenix Arizona I'm
working out and
it's Ramadan and I'm not working out but
I'm just doing an interview and I'm
doing an interview with this guy
and it's nice and some guys were picking
on them and I said yo chill I leave them
alone you know I got my Ramadan stuff I
think I'm religious so I come over I'm
talking to him and stuff he's very tiny
petite little guy thank you and thank
you sir and then he leaves I do the
interview
two three days come by SWAT has the
whole gym surrounded
I'm like wow and because I went out the
night before and I'm saying to myself
who else did I grab [__] why is Squad
here and that's it but then I said hey
if um if I go out to my hands it
wouldn't be the fans here right so I'm
saying what the hell did I do so they
come in
and they show a picture of me and this
guy shaking hands I'm saying [__] this
guy's probably have a losses I must have
definitely got this guy nervous or
something and he said do you know this
guy and I said well listen
I was promoting a fight and I must have
got a little animated they may have
gotten scared if anything happened on me
sorry I didn't mean to and they snatched
the paper back the picture made no Mr
Tyson he like you he didn't like the 20
people he shot and the eight that he
killed what wow he was the Baseline
shooter he was a serial killer he was a
boxing writer too the skinny little one
yeah Mike Tyson and serial killer check
that out no really the skinny little
white guy you were describing yeah
Mike Tyson
Dave hausner he housed me yeah check him
out that little [__] right look at his
hand look at it no I'm serious man
you're laughing look at his hand he's a
little small look he looks like yeah and
and enemy is so um it's the Tyson oh my
God I'm such a fan I'm like [__] I'm
like looking it's okay brother don't
worry what's gonna [__] with you and
look at they were [__] with him
outside you know what I mean I said
don't worry about it I got you and I
thought something happened you know
and he turned out to be a mass murderer
yeah he shot 28 or something but he
killed eight Rob scroll down and see the
story find out how many people he killed
he killed eight but I know he shot
around 20 of them dirty [__] and
he got he committed suicide in prison so
I guess that turned out great he
committed suicide in prison yeah
so you met again you've met a lot of a
weird cats listen a good schedule 29
people he shot eight he murdered what
yeah listen listen this is not my life
listen I must draw these kind of people
because I'm I'm in Australia right and
I'm taking pictures with people right
and one side of me after they get the
picture I got the Aryan guy right here
the Big B and then I got the Taliban guy
right here and it was a little and
that's what it was Mike Tyson went local
Australian Taliban supporter and I got
the Army and bike rider with my right
and my left
and I say to my people hey man how does
people get close to me right there you
know what they said
they bought a ticket
they bought a ticket that's what you
said that's what they said that's what
they said access well we were at the UFC
fight in Miami and you walked up with uh
Trump and I placed lost their mind when
you guys walk I don't know if you
Hey listen
Trump is jumping I don't like people
don't like what Trump is the man
jumping the man he had this fan base he
had been supportive and they're gonna
stick with him to the end
how has he been to you over the years
hey I always um
I never had a bad moment with him you've
never heard about him no no no did you
became very profited from him yet it was
just a great relationship when did you
guys initially meet what was the first
thing it must have been 1920 but I just
ate um I just had dinner with him a week
ago
in Mar-A-Lago where were you how was
that that was awesome me him Byron I
mean
um Byron and his mother and son Baron
and his mother and it was just off the
hook man um he's so smart the young kid
Baron is smart
seven feet tall now with his feet he's
six eight but generally you're very
intelligent I've hurt a lot of weird
stories man these kids they were saying
that they could artistic this guy's on
top of this game intellectually that at
16 years old 17 17 now got it was
Melania there yeah she was there as well
how was the your interaction with her
what is she like awesomeness like um
the president's wife the First Lady
you have a similar kind of relationship
with the current President Joe Biden I
listen
I think I said I didn't I didn't have
the opportunity to actually meet
President Biden I briefly met his son
Hunter
and um Hey listen we're out here we're
trying to make this the best country we
possibly can and there's certain people
that believe they can do it better and
that's just what this is all about
nothing personal have you spent time
with the governor of Florida with the
santis no I didn't have the opportunity
I met him at
maybe a football game we were in the
same
um Booth I believe what they call that
again yeah
so you're an East Coast guy East Coast
hip-hop did you I've seen stories with
you and Tupac and I've seen you talk
about Tupac a lot and it's emotional
stories did you ever have any
interaction with Biggie or I mean listen
I first met biggie when I came back and
I fought um
[Music]
either with Peter McNeely uh
Peter McNeely are either Frank Bruno and
um I had a party at my house and he came
biggie yeah and at the time I was really
religious and I was a prick and Hey
listen he kept can't drink so he shot
the drink down came in the house and he
was very impressed he asked how much the
house close and at the time it was six
million and that was cool to him back
then but he was to continue to live it
would have been like buying a candy bar
for him but listen to him and he was
just a cool guy then I met him again at
nails
it was just a really nice cool guy how
different were were he and Tupac
personality-wise
Biggie's smooth laid-back guy
pocket the real energetic power feed the
personality boom explosive
but they both geminized too
you know who else is the chairman oh
Trump shoot Elvis
uh Marilyn Monroe Brad Pitt Atlanta
Jolie John Kennedy they're crazy they're
crazy my wife said my wife's a Gemini
she's off
we got time in common cause I'm a Gemini
yeah
listen listen don't have they they don't
let grudges go Gemini's no they need to
chill out on grudges we got to go
through a list of Geminis you've crossed
and say you know what I gotta call these
seven guys if they get mad at you oh God
they want to kill you
comedian wives favorite comedian of all
time you've seen a lot of guys who do
you like the most
oh man so many people will get mad at me
I'm from the 80s
and um I just um personally my personal
I like Eddie Murphy Raw yeah
by the way they love the guys listening
to surpass them and all that stuff but
he was different he was different he was
different Eddie Murphy yeah
you know most of these um imagine living
the life of a comedian
and you have some bad nights and stuff
and you wanna and it's very easy to be
discouraged from being a comedian very
sensitive people want to do well
overachievers
and they can have um
they have a Arena of 20 000 people and
one person won't clap and they focus on
that one person now twenty thousand
people losing their mind but a comedian
forgot that one person that they don't
know the guys on drugs tired
they may start attacking them no serious
they have twenty thousand hundred
thousand people going crazy they see
only that one guy that's not clapping
that's just is that how you were as a
fighter or no different for Fighters
no it's a little different from fighting
so you but when I must stay doing my
show I'd look that that have that you
see that from the show side I need it
all right now quick when you were
fighting was there like that one sports
commentator where you're like this
mother you know every single time he
never gives you was there anything like
that or not really there was always
people but um I didn't really care the
um you're nothing the people don't say
you're the champ thing you're nothing
you don't have to have the belt for the
people to be the champ the people make
you the champion really you fight
everybody fighting and you win and they
think people that's one that's been
great Champions but still the people who
gave our lead the champion he's our
champion no question regardless half the
building that he's our champion like are
you following what's going on with uh
Jamie Foxx he's not feeling well there's
something's going on yeah they said
stroke I had no idea what happened to
him yeah you pull that up
we were at a restaurant a couple months
ago in L.A and what was the restaurant
the steak uh uh remember the restaurant
in L.A anyway
yes yes and he showed up and looked
really good and then all of a sudden you
hear the stories about
uh uh Jamie Foxx was the Chicago area
facility Hey listen we can't anticipate
that next breath we don't know when
we're gonna die
after we leave this bad stuff can happen
is he still doing the the movie or no is
he still uh because what wasn't there
like stories of him playing your life
well it was a possibility you know I
don't know what's gonna happen now but
you know it's a strong possibility yeah
he uh uh because you know Jamie's closer
to my age so in order to do him they
were going to do what they did with um
Benjamin Button you remember that make
him look younger type of deal yeah I
mean they know how to do that absolutely
has there any been any actual news uh
news on what this medical condition is I
mean Jimmy Fox is a young vibrant
healthy guy
Hey listen um if we don't know by now
they don't want us in there
you know what time come on man stop I
gotta wake up a question for you
question for you uh Mike I had a guy on
because for me I have this weird
personality where you know I want to
know what happened to the Shah when we
escaped Iran and I went to Germany lived
at a refugee camp so I want to know what
the hell happened to Iran right I want
to know my parents and you know one's a
communist one's a uh imperialist I want
to know why do you believe in communism
so I have to go read the book on Karl
Marx no how communism no yes so for me
John F Kennedy assassination I'm like
who the hell was so I've interviewed
anybody I can possibly yeah get a hold
of to learn about John F Kennedy right
there's Tupac was one of them because I
have a painting in my house I'll show
you today in the painting there is John
F Kennedy there's Einstein there's
Milton Friedman there's MLK there's
Tupac there's arts and Senate there's a
shabiron and Lincoln and one empty chair
right
um communist ideology black panther you
know those numbers that's right yeah
very interesting right very was that
yeah that painting breath if you want to
zoom in uh Tupac's to my left if you
zoom in on the bigger one yeah right
there anyways you'll see this here but
Tupac when he passed away I was so
curious I said what happened to this guy
who was behind it you know the whole
thing with the fight you know he's at
your fight he's gonna get to the fight I
think you guys were supposed to spend
spend some time together and then I
interviewed Greg kating and if you know
who Greg kating is Greg kating are you
familiar with gray cating no Greg kating
if you can pull up his Wikipedia Greg
kating
is the guy that
um he's the guy that was doing the
investigation On Tupac I remember this
okay so they had a little um television
show about this yes you're right
absolutely and he was known as the
multi-law enforcement task force that
investigated the murders of rap stars
Tupac and Biggie that's the Wikipedia
story about him right so I said so who
was really behind us so in the video
when I interview him you know how
somebody's trying to arrest him like if
you've seen a movie American Gangster
and they got these pictures is this the
guy at the top is this the guy so I have
50 different pictures with magnets and
he's putting these things up on if you
go to the video you'll see how I set it
up with great kidding by David and I
said who is really the guy behind it he
says well we first thought it was this
then we first thought it was that and we
first thought it was this and we
everything's going then at the end the
conclusion after multiple conversations
with him and different people it came
down to Biggie and to me there's there's
so many right there if you can just zoom
in that's the way we had it so we're
kind of going back and forth to see who
was behind the guys that killed Biggie
Tupac easy I'm A hip-hop guy I grew up
to all this stuff with NWA this is my
like you know Straight Out of Compton
was a movie I watched God knows how many
times because I listened to all of that
stuff I'm an L.A kid so why is it that
so many people in music and Hollywood
feared this guy did he as if he's
Untouchable and even the oh sugar daddy
not sure she said biggie but you meant
I'm sorry I meant to say Diddy not not
biggie if you punch in on the picture
here you see you see Diddy you see Suge
Knight uh and then a lot of their
cohorts down there but two pocket biggie
at the top as you were passing yeah so
so what is it I mean everybody is in
there so what is it with Diddy that so
many TI called them out 50 cents at one
time on uh uh Charlemagne God's podcast
you know breakfast he says he says one
time did he said hey let me go buy you
some clothes let me take you shopping
he's like well you want to take me
shopping what are you talking about so
T.I called him out 50 called him out but
some people are afraid what do you what
what do you know about because some
people are talking about there's ditty
involvement with Jamie and something
happened because he was calling him out
for some of the parties he was putting
up is there anything you have opinions
on did he have you had any experiences
with Diddy
no um just unknown for a long time got
it and with you he was chill he was good
he was awesome guy yeah
um I know him before he was um Diddy
and him for a long time when I when I
first became champ I knew him I remember
him he used to have crates when he's had
my After parties and stuff also when
they were throwing parties
I remember this is when he was the CEO
founder of bad boy well I don't think he
was a bad boy yet no he wrote him Damon
Dash and all those guys they weren't
they weren't on yet
I was I was like the First Street guy
that really got on you know I'm talking
about a guy doing crime in the streets
that became a television guy and
everyone knew it was a celebrity had
fancy cars that was the first this is
all in Brooklyn I'm the first of all of
our generation of that kind of that
cruise you know the street houses that
really blew up like that you guys all
knew each other yeah it's the same era
listen um
this young lady that worked for my
company and she started saying names to
people I remember when I was 11 12 years
old and it just it baffles me that you
think you know you got away from these
people you'll never see him again you
knew them and you at the worst of your
level or heard about them and you're not
the only one God had his hands on these
guys made them with successful too
in the sea you have to know them and see
them at this level of the game it's just
mind-boggling I mean it's really I'm
almost like proud in a way when you see
them you know what they experienced in
life and now they became respectable
citizens
I guess I'd say you know how you're in a
class of 82 or class of 90 whatever you
you're all coming up you kind of seen
who made it from your class I guess
that's how to see it when you're coming
up from the streets yes at the same era
who else were the guys that during that
time that made it big out of all of you
listen there were um some rappers didn't
know people didn't know about that made
it real big and not just from rapping
but from writing and it's just listen um
I come from Brownsville Brooklyn very
competitive you know normally either you
succeed
um probably 60 of the people don't have
their high school high school diploma it
might be more but it's just the school
it's just the neighborhood for people
that normally fails it's a failing if
you don't have sports you're not a
lawyer or whatever yes you're not going
to make it you're not going to do well
you know it's very competitive very Dog
Eat Dog people who are your friends at
one time next thing you know they turned
on you come over the house I need to do
something for me man
or they go over your house and they kill
you and Rob your house for your drugs
and stuff these are the people you lived
in the sandbox with
when the drug game yeah when the drug
came nodding over here when the drug
game started in the early 80s you know
when I started the people that you were
robbing what you're friends with and
everything next thing you know you got
different gangs in your shoes all these
games we all grew up together all the
people in his gang all the people in the
gang over here some of them are related
and now they're killing it killing each
other we're all friends to go up there
Mr Robin still together go to the
shopping together with the robin money
smoke our weed drinking together when we
were kids and next thing you know I went
over to my house after I'm doing good in
this box and stuff wasn't Champion but
almost I was making money so somebody
gets shot or go to the hospital to see
him and then somebody else got killed so
I go to the funeral to see him but the
guy went to the hospital if the guy that
killed my friend I'm going to the
funeral for
I'm crying but my friend is in this
hospital he's shot and let's say no I'm
going to my friend's funeral but he shot
my friend
that's crazy right it's really crazy
yeah like earlier we were talking with
Michael about uh Power players in sports
power players in the mob Power Players
and politics and I said who was the
power player mob he said chin right and
that was a guy that would run everything
so you kind of had to run Vinnie right
Vincent chin huh yeah got to play like
he was crazy
yeah look at he used to be a fighter I
heard yeah he was a fighter he was a
good fighter too
yeah then he kind of confused what Mike
was saying that he was a little bit uh
mentally off like he was crazy and he
was trying to he played good he did a
good job for a bunch of years for 30
years making money up his ass
just yes go ahead but people ask me that
[__] Michael was he really crazy and I
said well look to play Crazy for 30
years and get away with it you got to be
a little patient eventually you'll
become that part yeah but he was he was
crazy as a fox he was very smart and
from what I know about him he was a
monument from the beginning that's why
Giovanni got him to shoot um Costello he
was he wanted to do it yeah
yeah a very smart guy have you ever met
um Mr Costello Frank Costello no never
no you know what but he's the one guy if
I had if I had to pick the the ultimate
mob guy that you wanted to be it would
be frank customizer
smart Patrick he called him the Prime
Minister yeah he knew how to get around
people he had political connections you
know he ran the he was he was brilliant
guy
on the roof thing too yeah that was his
mentor yeah I mean if you the movie
monster on the dwarf thing yeah
yeah he's a Jewish guy but he created
the concept of the five families right
Arnold rostein did this yeah Ross and
and Maya Lansky too I know to let you
Luciano gets the credit for it because
he was there but it was Rothstein and
and Maya landscape two Jewish yeah they
made this into a business basically
before that it was a lot of guys running
around killing each other gang stuff and
all that but they organized it
yeah he was uh didn't you watched a
Meyer Lansky movie did you watch the the
recent one yeah I didn't think he wasn't
crazy about it no I didn't think it was
that good I wasn't crazy about it yeah
it came out about a year and a half ago
or something were there Mike were there
power players in Hollywood where when
you made it and they're like we can
really use this guy to make a lot of
money and they started calling like guys
that people don't know not guys like
people know Hey listen um I made all my
money with my hands I didn't need
anything else I did some Pepsi-Cola
commercials and all that stuff but all
the money I made with my hands the
majority of it
yeah no I mean
and a lot of people are in highlight
reels because of you uh uh on the on the
opposite side because of your hands it
was and you entertain a lot of us hey I
had a great teacher yeah great teacher
yeah that's no question about uh this is
the the second time and the amount of
influence cus has that you always bring
back to giving them the credit that you
give it's it's the only reason I'm
asking a question about Power Players is
in the political world right now you're
seeing Tucker got fired and I think you
did something with Tucker right yeah
it's been the weekend with him I thought
it was great yeah and and you're seeing
he gets fired and you see Don Lemon gets
fired and you see all of these things
happen and one is on the left one is on
the right I'm trying to see from a guy
that's been in this space where there
are guys behind closed doors that uh
sometimes call the shots did you
experience that or was it more it was
more straight up than you know of course
everyone's heard or read the stories
about Don King and what that was like
I'm not talking about Don King I'm
talking people above Don King Hey listen
um
what would be my purpose I'm telling you
that
you know I don't know I'm sure somebody
else in the higher position that no more
could tell you more I don't know I've
never been to these secret parties and
stuff everyone's talking about yeah I
don't think I'm allowed they don't let
me go but yeah I've never been invited
you've never been invited no I've never
been invited to one of those strange
parties everyone talks about if Bill
Burr was on uh uh Conan O'Brien and uh I
don't know if you've seen this one when
Bill Burr is on Conan and he says you
know hey he says uh so hey uh uh Bill
did you vote no I didn't vote I think I
did I don't know if I vote I don't know
if I voted he says yeah right you know
you voted I I forgot I think I've
ordered or not obviously you know Bill
is not wanting to say who he voted for
so what do you think about the Trump
winning again Hillary Clinton he says I
got to tell you you know forget about
them you know he tells the teams the
greatest comeback you know the miracle
the hockey and all this stuff I've never
never seen anybody win the way he wins
he says so he says but who was the other
person doesn't the other person go to
those Builder what those weird parties
they put in San Francisco that the uh uh
do you know which one I'm talking about
Rob when Bill Burr tells uh uh Conan
about the After parties that these
higher-ups go to he says what are you
talking about he says you haven't heard
of these parties he says no he says like
I don't I don't know what I'm talking
about man we can just change the subject
and change the subject but uh it was a
it was obviously a funny moment but uh I
guess Mike you've never been invited to
those parties so going back to me I'm a
quiet taste man
I respect it going back to uh uh the
stories on uh Champions Corner okay with
men
uh I I ask you but I'll ask you Mike to
see what you think about it
um criticism gives to sometimes given to
men today saying men are a lot softer
today than they were before you know
they're not as tough as they were before
you know men are soft today and they
give different measuring sticks how much
they bench with their you know grip
strength and this and that and all this
stuff showing that based on these
markers and men used to be this they're
no longer dead do you agree with that
and if yes what do you think is causing
that
I think men are smarter now maybe not be
as tough now because
um just thinking 80s and 70s right it
was in your face boom like this that was
cool calm it's really not necessary we
do that my friend this and that it's
very hard to even get somebody to really
think [__] you when they when you cut
them off back and they don't do that
anymore before like in the 80s and 70s
somebody cut you off you're out of the
car [__] this and that Denise
because you got out of the car you know
it's not that now people nowadays that
say you or myself getting a cult uh
altercation with let me call my Modern
Man okay
he's not gonna fight the mighty man is
gonna have a gun or he's going to have
his phone to go right to the police
station you know he's not going to be
talking too much or anything like
yelling like we did that's not gonna
happen they're all packed now everybody
the woman everybody's packed now
so it's a different world altogether
that's why um when you see women now
they're very they're confrontation
they're very um confident you know
they've been through situations before
where they were successful and it's
definitely having a confrontation with a
woman she's your equal now she has The
Equalizer
if you think it's not true yes check
Florida Florida everybody could buy a
girl you don't even have to have a
permit now yeah right that's what they
call the gun the great equalizer God
made big man God made small men Smith
and Wesson made a sequel ever because
she always used to say it's Fifth and
Western made us equal
I love that I love that and Patrick when
we put this link up because people that
want to get early access to this
mentorship program it's called Uh Champs
earlyaccess.com Michael it's right there
if you look at it Champions Corner
Michael I I mean we didn't really
address it because
um Mike wasn't in the room yet but how
did this partnership
come about right Michael friend sees
Mike Tyson have a business together
entrepreneurs both from the streets of
New York that uh you know 40 years later
after uh
the initial come up how did this all
come about it was a no-brainer right
Mike yeah I mean listen you know I think
we both want to leave a legacy you know
we both went up the hard way we both did
the wrong things for a lot of I made so
many mistakes in my life and I mean I
can't even get to count but fortunately
was able to straighten it out you know
the way you straighten it out you've got
good people around you you got a
supportive wife you got your kids you
know you don't want to make those
mistakes anymore
and you know for me I really found out
in life I mean this you know I've had
just about everything I've lost
everything I've been up and down but
when I go and talk to people and they
look up to me and I'm able to give them
some encouragement it's the best feeling
in the world
you know when I go speak to these gang
bangers you're not going through a
prison and they'll say you know Mike
though we're going to give you the guys
that are on their way home they're in
the camp and I said I don't want those
guys I want the guys that are in here
doing hard time I want to talk to these
guys and I'll sit down with them and
because I have credibility like Mike has
we have credibility we've been there and
done that we see the impact that we had
on them it really matters and say wow I
feel really good about this you know to
those who have been given much much is
expected in return and I think you know
even though we've had a lot of Hard
Knocks you know we're pretty fortunate
and so you want to spread it around you
know and I when I'm thinking about this
listen Mike may be humble in this regard
but he's probably the one of the best
known people in the world everybody
knows Mike Tyson no matter where you go
so if you want a Maximum Impact and
really reach out you know in whatever
time we got left in this life I said
this is a natural we both came from
Brooklyn yeah we both understand the
streets
and uh you know to me it was it was a
no-brainer
yeah
when is it being launched
in July July yeah
so right now people get signed up so the
moment it's being launched you'll you
they'll they'll be able to get
registered get involved we're doing
Early Access now then we're going to cut
it off for a while so whoever jumps in
now will be the first ones in there and
then we're going to cut it off as we're
preparing and then we're launch in July
we're going to launch it here
and I would like to say I'm a strong
exponent and having people on the show
defending their hope ideology as well if
we have a debate about somebody I don't
know and some gender because that's what
they're told we should have them right
here and
kindly politely debated about it you
know everything should be debated I
believe that's my my opinion do you like
debates none of the food that I like but
debates but everybody has the chance to
believe what they have to say present
their argument yeah we see for ourselves
exactly exactly absolutely I agree too
that's one of the problems I think we
have everybody's screaming at each other
all the time but if you can sit down and
hear somebody else's side of the story
because sometimes you don't know what
motivates them to do what they do you
know it's good to to get that out talk
about it is that what's the format going
to be so if if somebody is on there what
is the content in the Champions Corner
well listen we're not only into
mentoring young people but personal
development telling people really how to
be the best possible person they could
be how to give them business advice
because look Patrick you know this
better than anybody who knows what's
going to happen in this car it's crazy
which guy you know a lot of people are
struggling out there really struggling
you know and and they don't know what to
do
so it's not only Mike and I but we got a
team of experts that were putting
together so that any situation that you
might have we can hopefully provide the
answers for you whether it be in
business whether it be a faith issue
whether it be personal development you
got trouble at home you don't know how
to survive all of these things look
we're not the we're not the end-all for
everything but we have enough experience
to really show people this is the right
way to go this is what you should do
and uh and that's what we want to do you
know people that come through this
platform are going to say you know what
I really got something out of it I
really benefited from it and I go on and
and hopefully lead a little better life
Mike you bring up uh the concept of
faith I know that you've found
uh God Jesus while you were in the can
right I believe you also did the same
when you are you uh
before I went to prison you are but so
what role has Faith played in your life
at this point because you see in America
the decline in family decline in
religion decline in the community
service
um and you know we see that the pat says
this all the time that churches should
be packed these days you know churches
should uh revive America's greatness
what role has religion played in your
guys life and and what are people
lacking as they're clinging to politics
and political ideology and wokeness is
some may regard uh rather than faith in
God
man there you go Mike I just believe
that um I'm praise be in our lives
believe God should be
your personal
entity I don't believe God should be you
know that's my opinion you you shove
your relationship with God because when
you when it's your turn to go in front
of God you're going to be alone
Judgment Day your homeboy is not gonna
be inside your mother your father you'll
be alone you know that's what they say
so you have to have your own personal
relationship with God in any way you
believe it's possible that's better and
help you reach your Highest Potential
sometimes um
they can't do it from a
some people can't deal with religion
from a perspective of this is the way it
is from the Bible from the book and I
don't know everyone don't get into it
from that perspective they want their
own personal relationship with Allah
you're saying more spiritual than more
structured religion yes but they the
structure is good as well some people
some of us need the structure that's why
we have destruction the Quran in the
Bible because some people feed on that
alone that's their objective and um I
just think they all have their purpose
all religion has the purpose and all the
religion from my experience now came
from the
what do you call those people before
before the Egyptian Sumerians it's the
same the same religion they have at the
same religion in the Bible some parts of
the Quran Moses is a different name it's
the Gilgamesh you know so all religion
even though I saw this once before if I
could be permitted to say I was in Egypt
and I'm a Muslim and I saw on the the
carvings they had statues doing the
Muslim
um prayer the way we pray you know and I
said wow this had this had to influence
Islam a lot you know the statue that's
that's hundreds of you know like
thousands of years old
so we don't know anything about this
world we just know what we were taught
told we have no ideology who we are
where we came from who our ancestors
really were
you know
how about you Mike I couldn't have said
it better but you know personal
relationship that's what it's all about
I mean you got to have a you know moral
Foundation you got to have something and
and uh to me it's all about my personal
relationship with God and obviously you
know I go out and speak and share it but
I feel I'm obligated to do that but uh
it's just it's like you said you're
going to stand in front of God alone you
and him nobody else you know and so
often you know you get on social media
and Patrick you know there's people who
say this and that so many crazy people
online and I don't respond to any of
that because
you do care about what people say don't
get me wrong but at the end of the day
you know it's you and God alone and you
got to get it straight with him and I'm
I'm pretty heavy on donations too stuff
a lot but that helps any help me or
everybody that's that's why I realized
in my life even myself
even when I give my tips always give
tips out
it's a good thing but subconsciously I'm
trying to buy my way to heaven you know
you're not Fiat maybe you're buying our
way to heaven you need this you need
okay in the Jewish religion that's
called sadaka you know really it's
almost the doctor
there we go Tupac once said only only
God could judge me yes
but listen check this out imagine if we
were no religion no it would be yeah
we'll be brothers
we didn't have no religions and we had
four guys together we'd be brothers
right we all have the same belief we
don't believe in God earth religion you
know we Brothers there's always religion
because religion is just an action
something that's um
repetition what we do we wake up every
day our lifestyles of religion whatever
we do is the concept of religion
repetition
belief
I can't wait for this to come out uh for
folks to take advantage of Rob if you
can put it in chat uh description and
put it in the the comment section as
well on all of them for people to be
able to go to and visit and sign up for
it's coming out in July Michael Francis
and uh Mike Tyson Champions Corner get
registered so you know once this is
being launched to everybody Mike and
Michael and Patrick We're going to
enlist you too yeah
absolutely we need them in your
intelligence yeah they're gonna make you
an offer your camera
you got to be a mentor I meant to is
that what's going to happen big time
we're going to be debating we're going
to be debating it's going to be a lot of
debates my debate mentor
well it'll be a lot of fun you guys got
the right people behind helping out it's
I'm excited about it can you can you
imagine this listen can you imagine
having a discussion about gender and we
have a a gentleman a woman of gender
right there and we're debating it that
would be so awesome then would you want
to be a part of that and ask them
questions
I'll see that I would love to see that I
would love to see what questions you
would ask I would actually be first of
all I think I would be good no why
because I have a daughter that's in in
that world
so I think um that's in that lifestyle
so I think I would be really good
wow I would be very objective
are you following this Dylan Mulvaney
Bud Light situation that's basically
been a lightning rod for debate this is
what you don't know
well I think you know but this is what
we don't want to say
are we are we fighting these people or
are we fighting these agenda people but
I saw them shooting at them are we
fighting those people because if if
we're fighting them right or if you're
fighting them
we're not good Fighters because we
already lost
we already lost he's wasting his bullets
he wasted his ass shooting at that
commercial in those boxes Kid Rock
you're saying yeah we listen they won
the fight already
we already did you say that the Kid
Rock's face because you were with him at
that UFC fight with Trump and Dana White
you were sitting right next to him and
he didn't shoot that commercial yet if I
would have if I would have said a
commercial
it was shot and it was it was um
it was previewed after the I think it
was like the next day or next week right
then next week right after yeah but if
he would
um talk to me I would discuss my
experience with um trying to intervene
in that world and I didn't get a good
welcoming you know um I love my daughter
if anybody failed her I would attempt to
kill them
and it's just her life and I'm not going
to stop her from living her life and
she's not going to stop me from living
my life you know but as a father I'm
always there to kill and die for her and
the father what would you have said to
Kid Rock in that regard
I wouldn't let them know he wasted his
ammunition
you know he just wasted his ammunition
really tell me how do you how look we as
men right how do you tell them how do we
um how do we intervene and stuff like
this unless you you do it unlawfully
lawfully
these um
the gender Community pretty much um they
won unless you're going to do some
illegal stuff like hurting them and
stuff but I asked from from just a a
fair fight I guess what it is
this ideology against this ideology that
ideology one what do you mean they won
um
you see they have commercials you see
they have um banisters that's um when
you see that
even as a human being from some people
they get our sympathy
they're they're people at their their
their small their small army fighting
the big army
sometimes little armies get sympathies
from people that were a part of this big
army or maybe some people in this Army
are siblings and somebody in this big
army or the or the leader of the army
has the siblings in this Army that he
loves
that's what I'm talking about
how this listen love is going to
overcome it all
you know I'm not gonna let anybody hurt
my baby because she let the um because
she wants to live that life you know I
maybe if I didn't agree with it I'm not
gonna let no one hurt my baby
it's just all that you're almost giving
it a David Goliath type metaphor yeah
and David won
you really believe me you know some of
the powerful people in the world have
children in that world that they love
why would you bet on Goliath when you
got bad David there it is for you Pat
but that's a deep conversation and
that's uh uh uh if you guys gonna have
stuff like that on there this is going
to be a very interesting thing Champions
Corner very interesting thing to to give
the perspective you gave
uh just even right now the last three
minutes that you you and him went back
and forth on that topic Mike thank you
for coming on Michael thank you uh uh
gang the links below uh uh I believe we
have a podcast on Thursday or Friday no
tomorrow
tomorrow's Whitney Webb is back here if
you're into uh Epstein stories
tomorrow's Whitney Webb she's written a
bunch of books about it uh we'll see you
guys tomorrow take care everybody bye
guys